[Applaudissements]
je voudrais tant que tu sois là pour te
dire ma
solitude pour te dire ma
lcitude de te savoir si loin de
moi je voudrais tant que tu sois
là
te dire mon
espérance et le prix que je P
d'avanceavoir un jour tout à
moi dans mon désert il n'y a pas de
fleur pas d'Oasis et pas de vent et si
tu venais plus souvent tu ferait du bien
à mon cœur mon pauvre
cœur
je voudrais donc que tu sois
là pour réveiller mes fleurs
éteintes ton absence comme une
plainte vient toujours me parler de
toi je voudrais tant que tu sois là à
l'heure où les nuages
passent tu es lgir mon
espace r qu'à te blottir
contre
moi dans mon désert il n'y a pas de
fleur pas
d'Oasis et pas de vent et si tu venais
plus
souvent tu comprendrais pourquoi j'ai
peurce que j'ai
peur jetend que tu sois
là pour mettre du rouge à mes
roses pour pour que serve à quelque
chose ces
mots que je pleure à m'y voir je
voudrais tant que tu sois
là pour partager la chambre close où mon
avenir se repose en
attendant que tu sois
là dans cet
univers dénudé où tout est
triste et
désolé je pourrais me sentir vivant je
pourrais me sentir
vivante près de toi pour qui je suis né
toi qui ne m'aime pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
assez